[Music]
happy new year
2022. oh man does that sound futuristic
your eyes bike down when you say it does
it really does i remember
i remember the movie um
uh 2010 a space odyssey when we were
kids i remember thinking 2001. well the
sequel was 2010.
i didn't know there's a sequel yes
indeed there was uh it was the starting
year round a really nerdy way the far
inferior of the two uh yeah but i
remember thinking how futuristic that
sounded or like went back to future two
yeah 2015.
we're living in the future i know i know
we're old men well every year happy new
year
do you do you have a resolution yes
do you want to share publicly sure oh
really yeah i thought you were going to
say no my resolution this year is to
make no resolutions oh really because i
never live up to all my resolutions oh
that's oh that's a good idea trying
something new mine is to be like i
learned how to pickle last year
that was one reason that was a
resolution it was learning something new
oh okay
but that worked out well it did but i
made 10 resolutions last year and i made
like six of them one of them was like
less phone time definitely didn't do
that that's not bad all right less phone
time but that's my 2022. i was going to
say some of those resolutions from last
year can carry over into this year
because you were too ambitious maybe
last year that's true my resolution is
going to be um be less public about
private resolution things that's good
yeah here's another resolution can i
give you a resolution yes make these
intros a little more efficient okay i'm
gonna start right now pow
could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
you're listening to life is short i'm
your efficient host justin long
[Music]
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
with me as always is my brother
christian my co-host and brother i know
you're trying to sound efficient but it
sounded like you said fishing
fishing yeah well you didn't say that
part of the resolution can't be to be
more uh articulate
in 2023 your resolution is going to be
to be more eloquent eloquent beach what
would the word be it's not eloquent or
articulate it's clear what's the word
for clarity of speech proper dictionary
yeah um
elocution uh i hope our parents aren't
listening
because they'll shame us how about
knowing this word i'd like to be have
less shame in the new year i'd like to
carry less guilt and for example i'm
really bad at receiving gifts and um i
was given a gift recently and i i didn't
receive it well i haven't been
and i think it hurt the the giver of the
gift you know so i want to be better at
um i want to carry less guilt with me
and and i want to and this has been a
resolution of mine in the past but i
want to um i want to draw more i want to
cartoon a little bit more and try to get
this is every year i try to
my resolution is to get a cartoon in the
new yorker new yorker
well that's that can't really be a
resolution no no that is something
that's assuming that i can't easily do
it vicious i know i know move but one
i'm yeah that's that's true that's not a
resolution it would be cool if it
happened though hey did you notice how
efficient i got uh in that intro after
you told me to
and i and i finished by saying i
punctuated it with a pow i did yeah i
thought that was strange well i think i
did it because
do you know why
i do but i'm pretending like i don't
well my resolution this year is to be
more honest so yes i do know why you did
that well why why don't you tell
everyone why i did it because
because our guest today our first guest
of 2020. yes pow i think it's a really
good first guest of 2020 oh yeah yeah
because not only is he extremely fun
and charming but he has
such a great energy about it totally
he's got a great way to like introduce
things uh introduce a year yeah i want
to i want to bring this that's a good
resolution i want to bring rob riggle
energy into this new year he's our guest
yes rob rickl who has rob regal energy
um he is no i mean and if if you're
still lost as to why i was saying pow
that means you haven't seen uh one of
the best movies ever made step brothers
and if you haven't you shouldn't be
listening to this podcast
you should press don't turn it off
permanently no no just press pause don't
unsubscribe
yes yeah but you should definitely see
that excuse me um
yeah he is so funny in that movie as he
is in all of his movies he's in all
those adam mckay movies he's in the
hangover
he um he he did that i don't think he's
still he doesn't anymore at the fox
sports oh yeah the pre-game
he does like uh he did pregnant but also
he also hosts that show where they're
like wiping out and uh a wipeout is it
white or like ninja warrior um uh-oh we
should have more we should no
but i don't know
we obviously don't get into that in the
interview no um
but but we get into a lot he's an old
friend i we worked together years ago on
one of the mac commercials i'm a mac i'm
a pc and he played um
well we talked about it i'll
let him and you also work together in
something else right yes going the
distance going the distance yes oh i
played for a second yes he is um he's a
scene stealer and yes that's always a
little intimidating because um
you know it's just that you're the
actor's ego wants that you want to be
the one to steal the scene or you don't
want a scene still you don't want
anything stolen from you
um and rob doing a scene with rob you
just have to prepare yourself for that
because he is going to do it he'll steal
it he's one of those people who pops up
in so many movies and whenever he does
it's always a good thing but see i like
those guys now when i was younger i got
i think maybe i was just more insecure
but i like
uh setting people up i like i remember
talking to jake johnson about this he
does it better than anyone and vince
vaughn does it so well but there's i i
find a real satisfaction in like setting
guys like that up you know passing them
the ball and he is because you know
they're going to do something really fun
with your john stockton oh god yeah
ideally that's such a great i mean
that's what i would aspire to to be john
physically and otherwise maybe future
guest that'd be great yeah although i
whatever what was it like passing to
carl malone
i would love to talk to him i heard he's
really cool he also was one of the few
guys who wasn't intimidated by michael
jordan
yeah he was he was like he was badass he
was badass yeah um you know who else is
badass wait can guys still be badass oh
i don't know we'll see 2022 another new
we'll see what the new rules are this
year hey let's get into the show uh here
he is my ketchup with my old friend the
very funny the very exuberant how
rob riggle
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
rob's stroking his beard it reminds me
of my dad my dad is a
philosophy professor he's a very bright
guy and he he would stroke that
like you know while he was contemplating
something and you did that you did a
version of that it's
this
multi
you know that i'm contemplating what you
what you just said yeah and also it
gives me a tremendous amount of relief
because it's itchy and it just feels
good it feels good to stroke yes
it's better than this which i do this
when no one's looking yeah rob reached
south of the equator
rob's forgotten it's a podcast and now
he's running a comb through his mustache
god is it burly
i bet you've become
uh like a real sex symbol for the bear
community
it's a it's helped look i got no problem
with that you know i mean if that's the
i'm putting out actually this is for a
role i never get to say that by the way
i never i've always lied to people and
told people the weight gain was a for a
roll uh-huh um
but i've never um yeah this character is
three pounds heavier than i am yeah like
i'm playing a really robust
guy
he doesn't work out much he's kind of a
nerdy well uh
he masturbates a lot too
it kills us a lot in masturbates yeah
so none of that is filming
yeah but that's the whole story stuff
it's very sandwich alaska very method so
you have to forgive me while i go deep
into this character
but this is actually for a role i'm
doing
a movie about david crockett
oh cool i'm playing a mountain man oh
okay they were like let it yeah let it
go and so i actually was i had longer
hair but it doesn't look good on me i
have really thin gross long hair like
the lead singer of tesla you know how it
just kind of matched to your head it
just kind of sticks down so i i look
terrible with long hair it's stringy and
gross so i was like forget it i'm
cutting my hair but i'll let this go
uh that's have you done a period movie
before no i've never i've never done
really a period piece uh i've done
period sketches but never yeah like
drunk history and stuff yeah but i've
never done period a piece or movie so
and this is set in like 1815.
oh wow so yeah something different
is that because you're such a great um
improviser is that is that gonna i
wonder if that'll present a challenge
cause i remember doing uh as i rarely do
those movies either and i did one um
that took place in 1865 and the director
robert redford hello what
did it is that too close to the mic no i
want to make sure that mike is picking
up the name
robert redford i got it
really good but but he said i was
playing like the sidekick kind of like
the best friend role and um and i think
he had hired me because he thought i was
you know whatever i thought so i see me
in comedies and and so he said uh joe
you know feel free to improvise
and it was which was you know it's
exciting flattering of course that's
such trust one from one of the greats
and two uh what a gift that's all well
yes but strange
well that this is the thing i yes on the
surface how wonderful and flattering but
um
then i found myself uh
because i wasn't familiar enough with
the vernacular of the time to like
really speak convincingly i think in
that time period so i i i caught myself
saying things like yeah all right you
know we're doing very modern
uh things like i'm trying to think of an
example sometimes
colloquialism colloquialisms yeah like
rolling my eyes or like
even the subtle things that i you don't
consider like when did they start when
when did sarcasm start you know and like
and and i i it felt weird and wrong and
and the script supervisor kept pointing
it out and i would say to
robert as he i have us call him i'd say
um you know was that okay he was like oh
yeah that was great
and i just thought he wasn't keeping an
eye on it but then i saw the movie and i
i realized he was going to cut it all
out anyway it's just like letting me
have fun
it's like i don't even think there was
film in the camera oh awesome well i do
i do like watching those period pieces
though like uh true grit you know i
thought oh yeah golden brothers did that
and the dialogue
in that uh
was so specific and so well totally
weird and and uh i i don't know i think
that there's well amadeus too um yes
you know that that that character that
tom holtz plays is kind of kind of a
modern
he's like a rascal he's like a modern
rascal but he's doing it in the it's
yeah i love that
uh that'll be fun rob are you when do
you do that so it was supposed to start
but we're filming it in uh tennessee
actually in the smoky mountains and i
guess the state state of tennessee has
really gotten on board with it because
david crockett's one of their favorite
sons
so they want the movie shot there uh but
there's a lot of coveted
uh concerns and restrictions that have
been uh you know put in place a lot of
protocols that have are prohibitive so i
think the the production has been pushed
uh
maybe to the beginning of 22.
you were born near tennessee so yeah i
didn't know that you were a southern
southerner i was born in kentucky but i
only lived there i was born in
louisville kentucky but i lived there
for two years so i don't remember
because you're a kansas guy yeah and
then i we my family moved to kansas
which is where my parents were kind of
originally from and they wanted to get
home so uh i only two years in kentucky
don't remember much filling diapers
that's all i did in louisville and then
yeah a lot of people do that there yeah
especially around the derby especially
around me
mainly in the infield uh who's got time
in those fancy outfits who's got time to
go to the bathroom nobody does you go
and you go in the hat yeah
that's why you have that that's why they
have those big
flamboyant hats that you can never wear
again there's also a reason why they're
so ludicrous you can't wear those again
it's not and you gotta soil them and
later if you notice they're all in the
morning everybody's had it out afternoon
not so many hats
yes interesting reason hello
i think we're learning a lot of secrets
here but then i moved to overland park
kansas which is my hometown overland
park kansas suburb of kansas city on the
kansas side um a lot of people don't
realize the kansas missouri state line
runs right through kansas city so
they're kansas city missouri kansas city
kansas
oh whoa yeah and so i was right in
overland park
we've talked a lot on on this show
actually about um all the great comedic
actors that have come out of that area
which is so strange i mean like
kat mcnamara's been on the show um
sedakis is from there uh so many uh paul
ryan uh paul ryan stone street david
dave keckner uh uh
sedacus um cat as you mentioned uh heidi
uh gardner who's on snl right now oh
right um i mean there's there's
something in the water wild in kansas
city um and uh it's it's awesome paul
was the first one to kind of break out
and or at least go for it and then once
he did i'll never forget because he went
to ku for a couple years and and he was
a year older than me and i went to ku
and i remember
both he wanted to be an actor so he went
off to the american academy in
dramatic arts in new york i believe
after his sophomore year or something at
ku but
i'll never forget sitting there watching
a football game
and a miller light commercial came up
and it was paul it was playing some
video game in front of some big screen
or whatever and i was like
oh
so excited i like ran around the room
because i was like oh my god oh my god
he got a gig he got it you got to party
got it
and it was such a happy moment
it made i think anybody who had that
thought in the back of their head like
hey maybe we could do this paul did it
paul did it made it real yeah yeah and
what does he have he's not good looking
or talented or anything i mean like if
he can do it that's the thing that's
what you know that's when you know you
know
there's really a lot of opportunity here
in america
um because you're right you know paul
struggles he struggles with those things
despite being a white man
um
yeah he uh that must have been
but i remember that back back in the day
when like somebody would get something
like that and it was like oh they made
it like that's it they did it
there's another light that's a national
spot fool
national spots
williams ford uh local okay yes yeah
that's it's a big deal yeah
but you but did you heart at that point
so when you you see paul in that thing
did you do you harbor ambitions to do it
then because i i remember meeting you
and you had such an interesting
backstory um one that that suggested
that maybe you didn't have those
ambitions that you
went right into the military yeah no i i
uh always had a dream to do comedy it
was always a dream there's always from
the moment i saw
caddyshack stripes ghostbusters i was a
child of the 80s so all those 80s
comedies everybody has their thing that
thing hooked me
but i just never
quite honestly i mean and now i'm
looking back on it but
i just didn't think it was possible i
didn't think it was possible for me
because i'm you know i'm this guy from
the midwest i don't know anybody in
showbiz yeah i've really done anything i
have stage fright you know so i was like
i could barely give a speech in class
what am i no kidding so i was like what
am i doing
but but rob that's surprising because
what forget like your prowess on stage
now and how gifted you are how how
comfortable you seem uh with improv um
from the first time i met you you just
seemed so like relaxed with it but
you were also voted most humorous
so so how
how is that
how does that work i mean like
how are you able to be so funny with
your classmates and then
have a hard time getting up in front of
them well i
i was uh i don't know i i i guess when
it came to humor i could usually let it
fly so to speak um and
and even then the stakes were low you
know uh because it wasn't like i was a
class clown class clowns were annoying
to me you know the guys that interrupted
class or
you know like look at me yeah doing the
the uh what is the armpit you know the
fart fart which it's a classic it'll
never go down right and and so you know
but that does after a while you're like
that was dynamite but we do need to
there's a test tomorrow let's can we
just focus up for a minute
yeah i remember
my bit that i would do a lot in this one
class was um i remember the day i
stopped doing it because i kept uh
pretending that i was reading i was
doing extra work in science class and i
would say our teacher was kind of like a
square type guy
and a little ned flanders and i would
say you know i was reading and i would i
would just come up with you know the
work of dr richard kimball i've been
reading dr richard gimble's essay on
this particular
cellular uh
issue and and he would say oh wow that's
really impressive i don't know about dr
richard kimball but um that is that's
really impressive that you were doing
that you know and and so one day i just
like i flew and it was all to make this
girl laugh this girl sarah nemeth and um
and that would do everything
i it comes up a lot on this show i mean
truly
uh and one day i said i said i mentioned
dr emmett brown the work that he was
doing with the flux capacitor and i and
i flew too close to the sun rob and and
he said um he got this look on his face
like oh my god it was like a kaiser soze
moment like oh i now see what you've
been doing
yes and he said oh yes uh i i love back
to the it was marty mcfly there mr long
you know he busted yeah busted me in
front of me i remember sarah turned
around and just had this like kind of
disappointed like and you probably felt
like this big at that point oh god i was
like that's it yeah that's it for me i'm
out i'm done yeah so for me yeah we had
a high school radio and tv station so my
high school had three lunches first
lunch second was the third lunch during
fifth hour and see that was a full hour
of class but then you got a half hour
for lunch so
so at lunch you know a lot of most of
the kids would go down to the cafeteria
some kids would try to run out get in
their car and go to mcdonald's fine
whatever
but um
so
i would have a radio show
that just pumped from the from the booth
down to the cafeteria
and i would
just do anything to make myself laugh or
my friends laugh and it was it's it's
that thing when you're bored among
comedians and you know this if we if you
leave us alone long enough or if you
bore us we're going to self-entertain i
would get on there and i'd say hey you
know because we get free albums the high
schools but they were all the junk
albums that nobody wanted so i remember
we got an album and it was from a band
called halloween and it was a heavy
metal band and they were all dutch and
and you look on the back of the album
and it was the worst hair band you ever
saw in your life you know dramatic
makeup hair to the ceiling skin tight
leather pants and all this stuff
and their names were ingo and kai and
you know i just remember looking at
these guys this is the most ridiculous
man i've ever seen so i would say hey
everybody uh welcome back to ksms we got
a special treat for you halloween is
with us i got them on the phone right
now they're a middle of a world tour i
cannot believe they took the time to
talk to us
kai kai you are the lead singer of
halloween
what is it like where are you can you
describe where you are right now and
then you know
who is this
i'm doing an english accent but these
guys are dutch
you know and so i would do a whole
interview with myself as halloween
and they would say terrible things and
i'd say hey guys this is a high school
you can't you know you can't say oh oh
sorry so i just i'm just sorry but yeah
that's not as i have so much sex you
know sex what we do so we do shout
outs
banging you know banging banging birds
i would do all these things right but
then i would um i'd do a old classic bit
which is on the on the
board as we call it uh there was a thing
the master volume and the master volume
was the key to everything because we had
the mic we had the term this is
turntables we had a mic and turntable
yeah and so i would say hey that was
another you know hot one from night
ranger uh coming up next uh you know a
little pow and then i would i would
slide up the master volume and i would
lean into the microphone and go oh thank
god that [ __ ] shit's over with and i
would keep talking while the music was
playing but the microphone was on a mask
level so it was higher than the music
right so
i go [ __ ] me i am so tired of this
[ __ ] [ __ ] everybody's [ __ ]
[ __ ] the dog around here what does it
take to get a [ __ ] drink and i'd be
just drop f bomb fba oh my god miss
mcnamara our our
teacher uh would i could hear her
running from the cafeteria oh my god
click click click screaming the mics on
the microphone is on it's still on
and she would come blazing into the
studio
and and she goes guys guys the bikes are
on the mic
oh god oh and i
i would take the bastard i go oh my god
i'm so sorry i
the master was up she goes guys
seriously we could hear everything you
were saying you guys were cussing and it
was terrible so everybody heard that i
mean everybody heard that we were like i
am so sorry
i'm not kidding you we did it once a
month
for like two years she never figured out
she never figured it out she never she
just thought we were incompetent idiots
that didn't know how to turn the master
down
no
what
terrible mouths the second the second
you know like hey everybody i hope to
see other football games
who had like potty mouths but like
yeah take a girl with you have a have a
great day it'll be a lot of fun way to
go raiders
[ __ ] this [ __ ] i mean it was just on
a dime it was on a that is
so
funny what i can't believe that no none
i mean so the students must have known
oh the students were little yeah and all
my friends everybody would love it but
and then like they would have on the
back of the announcements you know like
hey don't forget the big you know toy
drive you think this that the other
right
we'd read announcements and on the back
of the announcements it said in all
capital letters bold underline do not
read
and it was teacher absences
oh boy so you know flip it over and like
hey mr minster is in here today i wonder
where he is oh i know hung over and then
we would just start going down through
all the teachers and listing where we
thought
yeah they should they shut us down on
that one pretty early but i mean just
anything anything you can't give
a high school kid a microphone yeah you
can't do it i can't well that's probably
why it hasn't been done since you are so
good rob at like outbursts i mean when i
think of like your great stuff and
you are like you must get this all the
time people must just scream pow at you
pow i get a lot of pals uh i bet
terrible times in the airport
in restaurants
you know
you know and
probably without any context sometimes
yeah and a lot of lean ins i hate to do
this no you don't because everybody
everybody says i hate to do this i don't
want to be that guy i've said it i've
said it i know i know and and then they
go and then i know and then i see the
camera creep into
and they go can you can you give me a
pow
and i'm like oh wait you know i'm like
we're in a restaurant or we're on a
plane or die yeah so i'm like i'm gonna
do a pal but i'll say hi or we can take
a picture or something and it's always
say pow pow tony you big [ __ ] i'm
like i don't know tony i don't tony
might be a kid tony might be a child
yeah yeah mobster i don't what are you
asking me to do here
you know
as they bring me tony bring me a shot
that they bought for me which i'm like
i'm not drinking this poison oh oh so
well
yeah i i had a uh another name dropping
story vince vaughn uh told me a really
good trick to like when he gets shots
because we had been getting these shots
from people at this bar and and he had i
said i can't believe you keep taking
these shots and because everyone wanted
to buy him a drink you know he's like
he's the party guy absolutely
and um and and he said watch what i do
with my hands well i'm not taking the
shot jam that's crazy i'm taking all
these shots from strength and i so i
look next time and he did this little
flick of the wrist right before right
before he shot it it was just like but
it was almost imperceptible and um i was
like [ __ ] that's great you know and uh
so i tried the next time i was out um
that happened to me bro bro do a shot
and it's never like
there's no hint of respect in it it's
just like hey you hey percy do this with
me
you know that's what i get anyway you
probably have a much different
experience but it's like hey nerd i'd
like i'm kind of mad that i'm like
giving you respect you know any sort of
time and so i tried to do it i did it
with i was with my i don't know if you
know kyra o'donnell i did it with keir
and i i flipped it down and i didn't do
it properly and and the guy goes right
away i thought it was so cool i was like
yeah thanks man he goes
whoa and he looked right down at my feet
which were now like soaking wet with the
shot and he
he said uh did you just and i was like
no
no no that was a bird that shot burns
i'm feeling it here i'm feeling
i dumped it down the old gullet if
that's what you meant yeah did you mean
did i slam it yeah i did
[Music]
cerebral is an online mental health
service that offers prescription
medication counseling and therapy you
know how much we love therapy for
anxiety depression adhd insomnia and
more it's one of the few services that
provides prescription medication online
through a licensed provider and ships
medications straight to your door and
you so you get to skip all the pharmacy
lines you get unlimited messaging with
your care team with the cerebral mobile
app it's like having your personal care
team wherever you are you connect with
your counselor and therapist on your own
schedule through your laptop or the
cerebral mobile app you can schedule
sessions based on what's most convenient
for you you can get affordable
treatments that are one-third the price
of traditional therapy as much as we
espouse the benefits of therapy the
truth is it can be quite expensive and
it can be hard for a lot of people to
attain so cerebral makes it a lot easier
treatment options are available with or
without insurance so even if you're out
of network they'll provide you with the
necessary paperwork so you can easily
submit a claim simone biles is their
chief impact officer she's a huge
advocate for mental health as i'm sure
many of you know and
she is also an advocate for reducing
stigma around getting treatment it's why
she loves using cerebral for listeners
of this program you can receive 65
off your first month of medication
management and care counseling at
cerebral dot com slash long so go to
cerebral.com long for 65 off your first
month that's just a total of 30 dollars
to get started join cerebral today on
their mission to make quality mental
health care accessible and affordable
for all
hey life is short listeners i want you
to imagine that you're on a warship in
the final days of world war ii you're
excited to go back home looks like the
war is ending you've just delivered the
necessary parts for the atom bomb
but then disaster strikes your ship is
struck by enemy torpedoes and within
minutes you're floating in the ocean
fighting for survival from wandery
against the odds is an immersive podcast
that puts you in the shoes of resilient
people surviving harrowing ordeals in
their new season you'll hear about the
infamous sinking of uss indianapolis and
the survivors fight to stay alive it's a
fascinating story you probably know the
story of the uss indianapolis from the
famous scene in jaws that robert shaw
recounts um it is harrowing to say the
least sailors who survived the attack
were stranded in the open ocean for
uh five days i believe they endured
brutal weather
rough seas dehydration salt water
poisoning hallucinations and it was one
of the deadliest shark attacks in
history
against the odds has the harrowing true
story of how the brave men of the
indianapolis survived the worst disaster
at sea in u.s naval history listen to
against the odds on apple podcasts
amazon music or you can listen a week
early and add free by joining wonder
plus in the wondery app
hello hello
[Music]
i know you were a big sports guy you
played football i did i was i was a
three i was a seasonal sport guy so i
played football in the fall i liked
basketball in the winter i liked
baseball in the spring and
golf in the summers
so you were a big guy in high school
you were like no i wasn't i was i was
rinky dick i was the last guy in my
class to go through puberty it was it
was mortifying oh uh me too i i mean i
was a late
bloomer it was between my between my
freshman and sophomore year that i
finally hit pure liberty that's ins
that's crazy rob so like freshman year
you're playing football do you are you
defensive back what do you play uh it's
funny to say that i was i was uh i was a
defensive back
um
i was surprisingly fast uh for my uh
size or whatever but uh i grew so it
really happened fast like
my freshman year i was running for my
life because i my biggest fear was that
uh some younger kids would want to fight
me and i would lose oh you know like
yeah there's something there's some
seventh grade bullies when i was a ninth
grader that like if i bumped into him
i'd be like what's up and i just pray to
god they didn't want any trouble because
yeah that would have beat me down and i
would have been more yeah as a ninth
grader to lose to like i said because
our highest our our high school was only
three years we had 10 11 12 and our
middle school was seven eight nine
oh okay so it was a little different
did you find though being small rob that
that that allowed you
that took some of the heat off or like
any sort of like bully attention like
that you were almost like two oh really
no the the i was a target i was a oh no
kidding i was a target i always felt
like i was a target uh because
um a lot of guys went through puberty
and starting in seventh grade definitely
in eighth grade and definitely in ninth
grade
um that's when most of you know ninety
percent of the years
uh you know their bones got bigger their
their muscles got stronger they got
faster their voices dropped so all this
was happening and i was still
prepubescent if i stepped out in the
hallway i was making a beeline to my
locker
driving my books and making a b-line to
class like no time for daily daily no
time to get caught in the bathroom no
time um so but then when it hit it came
on like thunder because the summer
between my ninth grade and tenth grade
years when i went up to high school so
now two junior highs are merging into
one high school so there's a whole bunch
of new faces of people that we had
didn't know
um and i got my braces off i think my my
face took shape because i think i was i
had one eye up here one down here and i
was like this and right like sloth my
soft head molded and hardened and
like processed toxic adventure yeah
and it stays as offensive to somebody it
stays defensive to somebody somebody um
yeah but it stabilized and then i got a
haircut i got the braces off and i grew
and people didn't recognize me when i
came back i've had over one summer over
one summer oh my god yeah were you in a
lot of physical pain rob were your
joints
yeah wow and i would sleep oh i could
sleep all day every day because my bone
it's the only time you grow is when you
sleep yeah and so especially during that
phase so yeah and then i went from five
i went from five foot
four
to six foot two by the time i graduated
high school so i improved ninth grade at
five foot four and i graduated six two
wow it's interesting that you had that
experience rob because you
often play and i don't wanna dwell on it
you've played so many different roles
but but the ones that i'm thinking now
like popular movies like the the one in
um stepbrothers and and hangover you you
play these aggressive kind of macho guys
so i i wonder if that gave you real
perspective in terms of like how to get
the comedy out of maybe i i do know that
that's probably where my comedy senses
started because when i was little
i had to use my mouth i didn't have a
house
yeah so to throw guys off of the idea of
picking on me i would try to get him
laughing oh you're right some of those
roles i do i play a big aggressive
character and i also had in my life
football coaches i had yes
authority figures i was and i was in the
marine the marines so i had drill
instructors and and commanding officers
and even the marines that you know were
under my command you know i everything
was a study for me i do remember
watching and observing people i did a
character on on snl
uh called leviticus who was this born
again street preacher who was way over
the top well i saw a guy who was a
preacher at the university of kansas who
used to come and he would stand on this
flower pot right there at the at the
quad it was called westco beach but it
was it was because out in front of west
coast hall that's where everybody hung
out during the day it was right in the
center of campus he would stand up there
and he would start preaching as i was
walking to class and nobody's listening
he had his his wife his wife was holding
a baby and like one supporter you know
and they'd be like oh preach on preacher
and i wouldn't think anything of it but
by the time class was over and i was
walking back home
he'd have 200 students around him
screaming i'll kill you i will kill you
and and i was like what is this guy
doing
and you know college kids are already a
little self-righteous anyway they got it
all figured out but this preacher yeah i
would watch him and he would just say
some triggering obnoxious things you've
ever heard and yeah and it was laughable
to me to provoke yeah just to get them
just to get them to stop and listen to
him right yes
he would
say things like
and he was very dramatic he was quite
the showman but he'd say cheerleaders
and then it'd be real quiet
so everybody looks i mean how you not
look right and he's looking good
our [ __ ]
you know and
you know
everybody would come unglued everybody
would go oh my god what is wrong with
you [ __ ] and they start
and he would be like he'd be like yes it
was almost like the emperor you know let
the evil let the hate flow through you
yes it's excellent
yeah they hate to overcome you and they
would the kids would play right into it
they'd be like i'll [ __ ] kill you yo
shut up you don't know what you're
talking about and he would bask yeah and
then he'd start talking about
and i just remember watching this going
wow this is good fascinating
guys i've ever seen
i think that's my earliest memory it's
so funny you mentioned that about the
emperor when he i remember thinking like
oh yeah i got it you know as a kid i was
like oh he's he's riling you up he's
like don't be angry like
you're he wants to know just yes
yeah he always like he was getting off
on it yeah yes yes
you were in the marine corps for 23
years i think when i met you you were
still you're deaf for sure yeah i was
still still in the reserves
and what did that mean um i remember you
telling me a little bit about it then
but uh what like what would happen if
you were let's say doing this doing a
movie doing stepbrother or something and
you got a call
during it how does that work yeah i
would uh probably depending on what what
the call was uh if you're in the
reserves you you know yeah you are
subject to recall uh which did you know
happen um after 9 11.
i volunteered though for that one but
but you can be recalled if you're in the
reserves um and
it doesn't happen very often but when it
does you know you you got to go that's
the deal
um so i did nine years on active duty
uh which was basically my whole 20s my
whole 20s were spent on active duty
and and then the last three years of
those active duty years um i was in new
york city
working active duty in new york city
working in a public affairs office right
there in manhattan um and that was seven
to five every day but every night i was
at the ucb theater doing improv sketch
taking classes i mean my teachers were
amy poehler matt walsh matt besser and
ian roberts
wow some of the best improvisers in the
world
is that where you met rob
that's where you met rob hubel yeah and
then huble and paul shear chad carter
owen burke
seth morris husky cordry like we all
kind of came up in that and if people
listening if you don't know all of those
names like you would definitely know all
those faces i mean
especially brian husky brian's that guy
who'd like to
talk about like where do i know you from
yeah i mean he is the ultimate where do
i know he's in and he's so good he's the
guy who never breaks he's the most
reliable you
google him right now if you're listening
to this look him up and i guarantee
you'll be like oh [ __ ] i love that guy
absolutely and he's he's awesome just in
general
you don't strike me as somebody who has
a lot of fear but like certainly not in
your performing um but in terms of
getting a call from the marines like
getting called up especially after 9 11
was there ever a part of you that was
you know waiting for that call to go to
afghanistan or something i left active
duty in 2000 so i was in the reserves i
joined a reserve unit right in manhattan
mtu 17 we're the only reserve unit in
manhattan
9 11 happens
i get activated my unit gets activated
that night next morning i report to
ground zero i'm working on the rubble
piles uh in the bucket brigades
and did that from september 12th to
september 18th
and then after that i worked at one
place plaza from september 18 to
september 30th
i had a very high security clearance for
my job i was a captain in the marines
i figured they're going to need people i
was upset i wanted to do something
everybody was upset everybody wanted to
do something but i was in a position so
i volunteered to go back on active duty
it didn't take long central command
picked me up november 10th which is the
marine corps birthday i reported
november 17th down to tampa which is
where central command is located and
then november 30th i was on a plane to
afghanistan so i mean
i did my time
i came back uh i got back at the how
long was that dude a year
now the whole time was not over in
afghanistan i went to afghanistan twice
in that year and i came back and worked
out of the joint operations center at
centcom between so um so two two times
over there and then uh the rest of the
year was uh back in uh in tampa
then i got back at the end of 2002
beginning of 2003
and continued doing improv and sketch
and and working with with rob hugo we
did a two-man show and just you know
building trying to trying to do what
everybody's trying to do and business
try to trying to get an agent trying to
get seen i was doing bits on conan and
then in 2004 i got snl and that was the
first job i ever got so it couldn't be
any any greener if i tried
and really didn't know what i was doing
and
gave him a lot of power over me and and
uh but nothing i regret i i the only
thing i regret is that i
uh i didn't do things my way i think i
was trying to please 20 masters didn't
please anybody and then i i kind of
forgot how i got there i got there for a
reason and i forgot that and instead i
was trying to go what what do you want
how about this how about well you lost
your voice yes i lost my voice a little
bit and that's again i have to be
responsible for me that's you know
nobody nobody can do that to me so i you
know i i'm not a victim in any way but i
i looking back i wish i would have done
things maybe a little different you know
i wish i would have been more of a
captain of my ship so to speak
rob what what were i'm curious about
what you auditioned with i'm always
curious because it seems like the most
stressful like high stakes audition did
you do any do you have impressions yeah
because the stand-ups were allowed to do
five to seven of their best minutes
whatever that is to a stand-up you know
give me your give me your five best
minutes i'm not a stand-up i wasn't uh i
was sketching improv so we have to do
three original characters and three
impersonations
each a minute long so i don't do
impressions i'm not i'm not good like
that so i'm more of a i'm more of a
characterization
i ended up doing um toby keith because i
can do a southern accent and i was big
like him all i had to do and for the
character i also was thinking of
costumes like how can i do quick changes
so people get it without saying a word
like i threw on a cowboy hat
you know and then you know sing a song
about making love in the bed of my truck
or something you know and it was it was
you know tacky and rude and you know but
people got it you know
and that week that i auditioned jeremy
shockey who was a tight end for the
giants yes giants
he uh he was a very flamboyant loud
mouth kind of character this flowing
blonde hair great tight end great tight
end but that week he got in trouble for
saying some homophobic things right oh
[ __ ] so i thought topical this is good
they'll love the appreciation they'll
appreciate the fact that i'm able to
grab something from the headlines and
make it work because it was like almost
like a day later so i grabbed a shocky
jersey and a blonde wig
and i i threw that on and you know acted
like a big dunsky you know tight end you
know for the giants and i was like uh
you know you know i know there's a lot
of people saying that i said homophobic
things or whatever that's not true and
what i meant to say was this and i love
working out with no shirt on and i like
what other guys do it and whatever i
just made up some stuff right
um so again you only have a one minute
bit so it's like you just do a one
minute bit as that character
i don't know i don't know who the other
guy was larry the cable guy or someone
you know who i was yeah he was like
you're done man let me tell you
something about this you know and i love
uh larry the cable guy by the way he's a
really sweet man but um so yeah those
were my impersonations and then
characters i did leviticus uh and then i
did a a gym coach who was 70 you know
nine years old and on his last legs uh
and was dying but had to teach the sex
ed class so
if i got too excited i'd go into a
coughing attack you know so i'd be like
i'm like sit down everybody calm down
the state says i got to teach you about
this sex now look here this is a pretty
obvious one it is but in case you don't
know it's a penis
you know there's just basically an old
man trying to teach a sex class dying
that's that's and then uh you know i
forget but you just create these create
these characters and do a one-minute
monologue for each of them and that was
it then your time's up
did you think then rob i mean was that
the ultimate uh you know was that the
goal and once you got it was it like
psychologically would it what did that
feel like yes it was done for
so when i was in flight school in the
marines i decided that i wanted to be an
actor and a comedian and if i the only
way i could do that was to leave flight
school and become a ground officer which
means i had to give up i mean i had my
pilot's license i had you know wow i
could have completed i was i would
finish primary i was in intermediates i
was headed down the pipeline probably
helicopters
oh my god and i was i was on dangerous
path but once you pin those wings on
they own you for eight years from the
time you pin your wings on so i would
have been oh wow i would have been in
for 10 11 years before i had the choice
of getting out well at that point i'd
only have nine years to retirement
uh it would be a bad move to do that so
i was like holy [ __ ] i'm in for 20 years
how did that happen
so i said well i'm never gonna i'm never
gonna get a shot at acting a comedian uh
being a comedian or an actor or any of
that
if i continue to fly so i remember i was
on the beach in corpus christi i was
sitting in my car and i was reading a
book and i flipped into the back of the
book and i said okay if i leave flight
school if i quit it's got to count it's
got to matter what am i going to
accomplish and the first thing i wrote
was i'm going to get on saturday live
that was in september of 94
september of 2004 i got the call to get
on saturday night
it took 10 years
wow 10 years two wars
uh
marriage a couple kids you know like so
many distractions so many things yeah i
kept that's what i was just kept driving
for and kept pushing for and working for
and it happened
i remember you doing howard dean yeah i
did howard dean of mark mcguire i ended
up doing toby keith uh i ended up doing
larry the cable guy i ended up uh did
leviticus
and i just got in some other sketches so
i was you know i think i made it every
show that year uh
so i was happy about that my most people
thought i had a pretty good first year
yeah yeah did you know adam mckay from
was adam still on snl adam was not on at
that time but i had known him because he
came to the ucb theater and used to
watch okay watch uh shows and and i used
to do this recruiter character uh a
marine corps recruiter that he loved uh
because
it was unrelenting i i would never take
no for an answer i would always have a
real excuse you know i would never let
anybody off the hook and i was just this
recruiter it was this recruiter from
hell and he thought it was he thought it
was funny
is that how step brothers happened then
yeah you know uh
actually the first thing he had me do
was talladega nights i came down yeah oh
yeah the part where i was playing a
sports caster on the speed network
and yeah we improvised like you do on
any mckay film you improvise your ass
off yes and so you just like i mean we
improvised for hours and we did that
scene every which way but loose and like
10 seconds made it into the
crazy you know like that's why
nothing made in the movie but we had so
much fun improvising and playing
that
that uh when he went to do another movie
step brothers i got an invite to come
join that and then i got invited to do
the other guys and then i got invited to
do the goods which he didn't direct but
he produced
and then got you know so i was very
fortunate to because i got to improvise
so much that he
he and i like to improvise together
because he would be he would be in video
village and he yells the fact that they
throw things oh yeah so funny he would
throw things and i would i'd have to
take a minute to get it together because
i know exactly what he's saying and i'll
be like god that's so good that's so
freaky yeah i know i know i'm like okay
i want to do this now now and i'd have
to collect myself because the smile that
would come on yeah because you're a fan
of god yeah yeah and he's so
good he's so smart with that stuff and
then it made you want to go i want him
to laugh i want to dazzle him i want to
share something so then it pushed you to
a place which was fantastic because you
get you coming up with your whatever you
got
well well then how difficult was it then
when you were face to face with john c
reilly and will which were like i i mean
that movie is one of i mean i won't bore
you with him people love it for a reason
it's like it's just the best and i think
it's the funniest studio comedy of that
decade i just adore it but but um i i
know i've worked with john
on a com on a day i did a day with him
and he doesn't break he's pretty [ __ ]
he's rock solid and if you don't get him
to break it's like uh
it's like when you score a goal on
michigan keep the puck
keep the puck man because it doesn't
happen very often right
so yeah same thing you get a laugh out
of riley man write it down put it in
your journal so
where were you what did they how did the
pow happen not to labor this uh what's
probably the debate total
total reshoot if you watch that on the
blooper reel on the dvd there's no
you've seen it there's a small scene
where i have a heart attack i die i come
back like we were improvising the [ __ ]
out of that was all we were making it up
we were throwing this at each other we
were just having a field day it was one
of the funniest days i've ever had in my
life
as far as laughing and crying just it
was so much goddamn fun the problem was
the scene didn't work because they
wanted will's character to be more
aggressive they wanted him
to
that he wanted it
right so we had to do this whole reshoot
and everybody was bummed because that
scene was so fun
ah so we came in and now will's
character has to lean into it he's like
i want it you know i've been snapping
next cash and checks and right so he's
he's leaning into it and and um
adam's character comes in and i'm i'm
adam's muscle you know i'm adam's
henchman right
yeah and so he's getting in will's butt
about the the whatever about the mixer
the catalina wine mixer
and so i'm ready for this i'm sitting
there the only thing i can think of is
just stare daggers through will just
i want him to feel this menacing
you know menacing
henchman just right there like almost
like a dog that's about to pounce
yeah
you know and you can feel it it's just
about to happen and so
so anything adam said i just started
yelling pal
as literally as a punctuation just as a
a exclamation point he'd say you know
it's the catalina wine myself
god damn it you know if i would have
been able to keep saying more i would
just kept screaming but
wow so i just screamed pow and then i
went i gave him crazy eyes right so i
would just stare at him like
i'm gonna murder you and i was thinking
i'm gonna jump over the desk and kill
you and i wanted him to feel that and
will
is so good he's so good and he was he
plays it's so great because he's he he
plays it as you should which is honest
and true which is if you're in that if
you're in that situation and your boss
is yelling at you and you're just trying
to process it you know and
and you're trying to talk to one guy but
the other guy's distracting yell you'd
be like i see why does he keep doing
that is what is he saying is he saying
pow like am i missing something this pow
means something like it was so good and
then you know that probably made you
laugh oh i mean i you can see a couple
times yeah as i'm grinding my teeth like
it's to keep a smile off my yes yes i
can kind of because i'm looking at his
face and he's dying you know and and you
know the rules of improv right obviously
you know yes and is a big part of it
well
adam scott you know he's he's like you
know you [ __ ] this up you know randy
here is going to eat your dick well if i
say no i'm not going to eat his dick
scene's over right you know all the wins
gone everything so i have to embrace it
i have to yes and it so i say
like kobayashi right that's my yes yeah
and then you add information like toby
so i start
and
you know it's just it turns into a melee
right because we're not going to deny
each other's moves we have to accept
that day we were improvising so funny
that day and the it's the most fun
though was at the mixer at the catalina
wine mixer oh yeah yeah
uh i don't like your face yeah i don't
like your face scene right yeah so that
was a hundred different versions the
first time i came up to him i was like
brendan how'd you get a body off an
island what how do you get a body off an
island now don't make me repeat myself i
think jesus robert you know my character
was randy's like randy are you in
trouble what is this 20 question are you
a cop are you writing a book how do you
get a body off an island like oh [ __ ]
you don't have time you never saw me and
i'd run off right that was one version
you know another version was me coming
up going
um let's say a guy's got some cocaine
and he needs to get it from one place on
the island to another place on the
island you know and and
you know again always forcing will into
the worst
my whole my heart he wants to please you
my whole mission which was to make his
life impossible i have to make his
impossible
so i just gave him the most impossible
scenarios that your boss could come to
you with and the last one we did was
your [ __ ] face man i can't deal with
your face now that's an impossible task
how are you supposed to do with anything
with this
and he was so beautiful he's like yeah
he's like all i can do is take that in
process it
and try to you know his response was the
most genuine honest responses yes yeah
it's such a good lesson it's the the the
stuff in that movie is so um
yeah it's
i i think a lot of people can people who
are interested in improv and comedy can
learn from like you're right he's
playing it you're both you know playing
it's so real yeah and and i have a
problem with his face and the more he
talks the more it annoys me he's not
doing you're not helping me now you're
not changing it now yeah and you need it
you're genuine yeah you're earnest about
it it's an issue
if you're not being a dick yeah it's not
like i'm i'm brady i'm not trying to
physically attack him yet but
but the thing is if he doesn't change it
i i got to change the forum well well
also the pow reshoot is interesting
because that has become such a that's
like a legendary moment now um and yet
it came from it was just a simplified
version of like this bigger thing that
you probably were like oh really i know
that feeling too of like oh they're not
using that stuff like that's the but
it's too much and it doesn't work for
the story and it's not um and so it can
get reduced but it's the same intention
it's just in a very simplified and the
fun thing is with the reshoot
they had you know they had scripted the
scene much tighter much
much more narrow much more narrow
but we got in the room
and we started playing and that's where
pow came from that's where international
waters each dick that's where you know
that's funny all that stuff but all that
came because the the three of us enjoyed
trying to play and make each other laugh
and as long as we kept it in the lane
like if we had gone off on some tangent
they would have cut it but we kept it in
the lane enough that
but i would imagine you're all so good
at staying in that lane i mean like
you're also
you know experienced at this point that
you know especially because it's a
reshoot especially because you know it's
being reshot for this reason like it's
gotta like you don't want other good
stuff to like well that and that's that
is something you do learn over time i i
will yeah because i used to go guns
blazing put it all out there and then
say i'll let them throw it out they're
going to cut it all so the best thing
you can do is understand what they're
trying to do in the scene and help them
get there
you can change the vernacular you can
use your own words you can spice it up
but as long as you're not going off on
these these
these flower petals and you stay in the
center and you keep it going they'll
probably use it
and if you can figure out
what your character's game is like uh
will will in step brothers you know he's
trying to please his brother he's he's
trapped you know he's trying to he's
trying to accomplish something he
doesn't want to trump so how can i make
that harder for him
because there's comedy in that
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
hey life is short listeners business
wars is a podcast from wondering that
brings you the full stories behind some
of the biggest business battles in
history in their new season you'll hear
about the fight between espn vs fox
sports to dominate the sports television
industry espn is the american cable
network that plays the trail for around
the clock sports coverage athletes even
change the way they play just to get on
sportscenter's nightly highlight reels
but right around the corner rupert
murdoch's fox sports channel started
gaining on espn in the us the sports tv
business is worth more than 12 billion
dollars the question is who will come
out on top fox sports or espn listen to
business wars espn vs fox sports on
apple podcast amazon music or you can
listen one week early and add free by
joining wondering plus in the wondry app
hello hello again
[Music]
rob the fascinating thing that i'm like
wrestling with is that you spent so much
time in the military and my
perception of that which i think is
probably pretty accurate is that it is
there there's a very clear um
social structure which is very rigid and
uh
you know authoritative um there's a
right
structure there is a yeah there's
but i guess i'm wondering like how does
that jive with
the the kid in high school who like was
can't you know will joke around and like
needs to like if you you you even said
it earlier you're like you know you
can't leave comedians in a room without
them entertaining themselves so how do
you deal with that environment with that
like rigid uh kind of a
it seems to be oppressive for comedy
like i don't know how how do you do that
how do you exist in that i never lost my
personality i might be part of a bigger
machine or a bigger team
and i and i have a role in that team but
i doesn't change my personality uh how
do you not joke around how do you know i
i do i do i just tried i tried to do it
wisely uh i tried not to do it in front
of my marines too much
i could do with my fellow officers or
fellow you know peers but you didn't
want to okay joke around in front of
your marines because you don't want them
to think you're a fool especially if
you're a leading club
in a war zone you know
they need to have trust and confidence
that you're proficient in your job and
that you know your business
which i always tried to project and and
i i did
um but i also was was me if there was a
if there was something funny that needed
to be said i could say it i i didn't
feel like i was jeopardizing good
conduct and order um you didn't feel
stifling i didn't i never felt stifled
um i knew there were rules that you
played by you know if the general came
up you didn't you know do the armpit
fart thing which i believe me crossed my
mind a hundred times but that was from
those from my inside laughs but uh
yeah you read the room you play you play
you you you play the by the rules when
it's time it's i wore different hats you
know time and place time and place so i
would always just when i needed to uh do
my job and be a marine i would do that
and it was very well very easy and then
when i was when it was time to play and
have fun
i i
do that and it was equally
well i imagine rob when you were in
afghanistan um which i'm curious your
thoughts now
uh of course it's been in the news we've
just pulled out of there um
was that one of those very high stakes
situations where like there's no real
room for i would imagine there's no room
for like joking around and being light
no no not actually the opposite uh when
you were out when you were out in the in
the town like if i was out
in mazari sharif and and this is early
2001 2002 so you know we don't have a
big footprint we don't have humvees we
don't have light our vehicles we don't
have
we're driving around in toyota vans
where we were up north uh
it was where the northern alliance was
they were our allies
but they were ran by three warlords
dawson
being the strongest of them all who went
on to be the secretary of defense for
their their government which no longer
exists but he had been fighting the
russians for 25 years now he was
fighting the taliban his whole life had
been war
he was one of the hardest man i'd ever
met in my life he looked at you and you
felt like
you were looking at a grizzled
30 40-year warrior who would know
nothing in his life but war and conflict
and death oh my god i don't know how to
ask this about sounding kind of lame but
what what is this what was the scariest
part of being over there i mean of
serving there what what not knowing who
was a good guy or a bad guy you're right
i think that was always you know because
i remember asking some of the special
forces we were coming from the airport
in a toyota van uh and we were coming
back to the
to the
we had this old abandoned turkish high
school which was a our compound we were
driving back to one day and i was like
how do you how can you tell because
those guys have been there longer than i
had
they were actually the guys from 12
strong and if you ever see that movie
they were those guys in a matter of fact
oh wow i play lieutenant colonel max
bowers in the movie 12 strong that was
my boss when i got there no [ __ ] i
reported to him i used to brief him
every morning and every evening and i
ended up playing him in the movie
oh my god isn't it rob that's wild yeah
wow no so the guys that were there for
had been there for a while and had
actually been hooking and jabbing with
the taliban and al-qaeda i was like how
how can we tell i mean i mean i see
these people on the corner everybody's
got an ak-47 here i don't know northern
alliance from taliban how can you tell
god they're like well generally the
taliban wears black they have longer
beards i said yeah but
from the last intelligence report so
they all threw away their stuff and now
they're wearing northern lines like yeah
well that's the afghan way is they join
the side that's the strongest
i'm like oh what's going on so the these
guys over taliban yesterday are now
northern alliance they're like yep
oh
my god you have to tell by the size of
their beards to try to gauge how long so
how do we trust who do we know how to
trust i mean how do we
like yeah everybody gave the old
yeah rob's giving the classic shrug
that's what that's so at that point is
it is it what's up does i see fear would
just grip me at that point i mean it
would have gripped me already i wouldn't
yes and no i mean i felt like uh
we we it was early in the war we had we
were making progress we those things
were starting by the time
i left things were firing up in the
north and south the north was pretty
secure we had driven to taliban out of
the north um so i felt like
the remaining taliban that were there
were
non-threatening um yeah yeah or at least
they had disengaged they hung up their
their weapons for the time being
but see that's it
we just don't know the same thing in
kosovo you know kosovo is
very tricky because you just didn't know
who was who
you were in kosovo as well yeah yeah oh
my god oh my god
having seen the stuff that you saw and
having been in those uh high-stakes
situations did you ever think like does
it make it easier than to go into a
world of comedy and showbiz where like
it's not life or death it's um does it
help put things in perspective yeah
absolutely it definitely helps
perspective-wise hilariously
fear-wise
i felt i felt better in combat zones
than i did my first time on stage and
the reason was it was such a different
it was such a different vulnerability it
was a completely different vulnerability
you know when i was
when i was in kosovo or afghanistan i
was trained i was prepared i had
means at my disposal i had a weapon i
had knowledge i had an understanding i i
knew how to do things i knew how to do
my job i knew how to do other jobs i
just i had been it's probably more of an
athlete right it is like it's a
preparation and and
whatever came i felt like i could deal
with
when i had to go on stage and
uh do i remember the first time was i
did stand up and it was at the comic
strip live on the upper east side
and i had taken a class because it was
right when i moved to new york i didn't
know what i was doing i just don't want
to be in comedy so i took this class and
i come from the school i love eddie
murphy
delirious and raw and you know he's a
storytelling stand-up which i love
that's how i want to do stand-up
when i took this class they were like
three jokes per minute set up punch set
up punch shut up punch moving on and i
was like but what about if i want to
tell a story and you know i'm doing
characters in the story and they're like
set up punch set up punch
so i was like okay i'm as green as i can
play so i was like i got to do it their
way so i i wrote like five minutes of
crap
i got up
i did it i hated it i remember going up
there i felt i felt more adrenaline than
i ever felt in my life i could feel it
in my neck
it was almost a state of shock because i
got up and i did it i don't remember
hardly any of it and then they were
videotaping me with an old vhs and
they gave it to me as i walked out the
door still in a state of shock and i
thought i have made the biggest mistake
i've ever made in my life i should have
kept flying for the marines what was i
thinking
right you know i this was the worst and
i hated it and i went home and i watched
the tape
and it wasn't as bad as i had remembered
it wasn't great it wasn't anything
landmark but it wasn't
as bad as i had painted the picture in
my mind
but i hated standing i hated that i had
all
somebody said hey regal i got a friend
that might uh might be of help to you
he's pretty he's done pretty well in
common but he
uh maybe he can help you you know i was
like all right who you know who is it uh
he's from your neck of the woods man you
you might know him he used to be on his
name dave kechner
and i was like okay so i called dave and
i was like hey we have a mutual friend
and he said you know you might have some
words of advice i'm sorry to bother you
and he had just left saturday night live
and he was like he's like yeah listen i
got some buddies from chicago who just
moved out here they're called the
upright citizens brigade
walsh besser amy poehler uh you know and
ian roberts
i was like okay because they do uh an
improv show called asscat on sunday
nights down at this theater you ought to
go check it out
i went down i saw the show
that was it that was it it was i felt
like uh belushi at the triple rock when
the light hits him you know
and i was like yeah yes dad jesus christ
i started doing cartwheels down down the
aisle
because it was it was amazing that the
show they did it was all improvised i
was like they're making this up as they
go it was so funny that i was like how
did they know to do that how did they so
i was hooked and that was it and i went
up to matt walsh after the show and said
hey i'm robert i'm friends with dave
kecker he said i should sign up take
classes with you can i do that now
and he was like yeah absolutely man oh
man that's great that was it and then i
just started working there
and wow that's that's so interesting rob
i've not i i it's just a dichotomy
between those two different worlds that
you're dabbling in and it's it's yeah
and then when i was like so so an
example of of my reserve time so i'm on
the daily show i leave yes now i go you
took over for cordray right yes yes and
uh yes because it was john oliver and i
took over for helms and cordray
so but it was all around the same time
it was all you know it was all within a
month or two of each other so i don't
know if it was helms or a quarterback
that i took over for but wow so so was
that that was after snl then that was
after that i think it was around the
time we met i think you would um
uh you have to go no that was my
daughter she just uh popped her head
into high so
she was spending the night with a friend
and she's back now so that's good how
old is she she's a senior in high school
and she wants to be she wants to be an
actor and she's good no yeah yeah yeah
oh
does that scare you at all um
yes and no only because i know like
maybe she'll take your parts
no does it scare you like just get the
light i don't need the competition right
now man yeah all right it's getting
harder
look at the grandest beard man
it's getting harder what is
what what is what's the fear no uh she's
uh the fear is i know a life in the arts
uh a life in the arts especially in the
beginning is tough it's just not the
most stable it's just tough it's tough
man you got to have two jobs
and and everybody wants the shortcut
everybody wants the life hack
there's not really much you can do on
that front maybe get a break before your
time but
and you still got to do the work man
it's it's i always compare it to uh
karate because you know you can i can
put a black belt on you
and you can walk around tell everybody
you're a black belt but you're going to
get exposed
eventually you're going to get exposed
right so i think that yeah the same
thing with acting man like you just got
to do the work you got to take the
classes you got to get on stage you got
to get your stage time you got to get
comfortable working you've got to you've
got to build your
ship
and then you then you put on that black
belt fine
because then when you get when you get
pushed or challenged or you find
yourself in an opportunity you won't
fail you'll be ready
do you have to go now do you have about
15 minutes oh just to finish that one
story so uh um
when i was on the daily show um you know
i was in the reserves and
uh i was right i've been promoted to
major at that point so i have when
you're a major you have to go to these
professional schools i had to go to
command and staff college so once a
month i would get on a plane in new york
and i would fly i'd fly to california
drive down to san diego down to miramar
air base and spend my weekend uh in
command and staff colleges taking
courses on clausewitz and mayhem and all
these you know
and so i'd spend my way and then i have
to take tests and all that stuff
and my daughter at the time who was a
little little tiny uh baby
she would uh
her and her mother would come down and
we would uh
i would play i would get out of class i
would meet them at the hotel we'd play
in the pool
uh i'd take him out for pizza then we'd
go back to hotel get her to sleep uh and
then i would study uh because i had
tests the next day
and then the next day they would go to
lego land while i went to class and
study study study
i would take my test we'd all get back
in the car they'd drive me up to lax i
would get on a red eye and fly back to
jfk they would go back home and uh i
would land at jfk monday morning and
then to go right to the daily show
that's crazy right how long do you
that's probably around the time i met
you on the apple commercial yeah i think
you were
but go go the distance when was that
going the distance was after i think
we'd already met on the apple commercial
um because because you knew hodgman a
little bit yes
yeah yeah
um and then yeah that's so the scene we
didn't go in the distance was um i guess
similar to
i mean you had that we we had a bit of
that dynamic where you you just didn't
like me that's right
you know if you keep the question simple
what am i doing the scene you don't like
justin got it i'll figure out the rest i
will figure out the rest i'll just make
his life well that's what it should be
that's i mean we're pretty simple
creatures like we um i i like that i
like that because then you can fill in
you're so inventive you feeling you did
film the rest it was such a fun day but
i was having to be the straight man the
like the reactive one but that by the
way to me in comedy the straight man if
done well there's no better there's no
better and i can i think
i think you
i think uh corel i think uh bateman i
think you're actually the best in the
business the best of the business of
being it's the best compliment it is i i
that's how i mean it i mean it that way
because to me that's where the comedy is
that's where the gold is if especially
if you do it right
yeah right
there's nothing better we we have like a
lightning round okay i was hoping
um what is your most commonly used
emoji uh
the fist bump
oh pow yeah okay i'll send that one out
um that makes sense uh if you could be a
professional athlete what sport would
you
do
oh yeah you'd love to go they live a
good life just beautiful scenery
fresh air sure
i mean i could be overweight i could be
hungover yeah i could still play the
game
that's awesome
um
if you could um if you'd have one snack
food for the rest of your life what
would it be milano double
dark chocolate
cookies i think or it's funny
haagen-dazs chocolate chocolate chip ice
cream oh wow so you really love
chocolate um yeah i don't do any other
kind really people like would you like
some cheesecake is it chocolate no never
mind i'm out
what's a movie that you um were really
looking forward to like showing your
kids you know like maybe a movie that
was important to you growing up uh
something that you you really wanted
them to enjoy
all the all the comedies from the 80s um
yeah ghostbusters is definitely up there
um stripes uh and caddyshack caddyshack
i can quote caddyshack all day for so
many reasons
you know sure some things don't hold up
from the eight from 1980 to now but okay
but some things
you you've built them up in your mind so
much and the quotes are so great and
and rodney in that movie was you know at
his best uh um so i don't know i just i
don't know
are you a what about bob guy
love what about bob i love you yeah but
i haven't seen it forever
actually i watch it a lot um
we my brother and i were really inspired
by those odd couple comedies and that's
that's one that uh we i i watch a couple
times a year i would say it's
and i find new things to really
appreciate about it you know
knowing more about the movie making uh
you know the technical side too i've
been really enjoying
watching those older movies like you
said earlier there um there's a real
patience to them yeah
there are scenes that are played out in
these masters or
very limited cutting you know um i felt
that way about stepbrothers and the best
stuff in the hangover too is like i just
recently rewatched that and it's patient
he like those guys really trust the
actors
and then uh uh just speaking of what
about richard dreyfuss
what a piece of gold what a piece of
gold oh man i mean he can do anything he
can do anything he wants i mean
goodbye girl one of my favorite movies
of all time oh yeah one of my all time
of all time he's doing a big performance
in that he he gets so wound up by bill
murray that he's he's never gone i mean
he's supposed to he's the struggle
within him is so good because he's
supposed to be the level-headed one he's
supposed to be this yeah yes and so he's
losing it and you feel it you feel it as
an audience member which is the best
but but that's the stuff you do rob not
to blow smoke but you're you are big i
mean like let's just take the power eat
the stuff in the hangover oh you got i
mean like you're you're really into like
those guys being tased uh and it's a big
thing but it's totally real i like um
you know i think it's a good lesson too
for people that you can get away with a
lot like michael richards is
big but it's not broad it's still real
that's [ __ ] for something there's
there's there's a and i don't know what
that is is there is that there's an
ounce of sincerity in it it's some sort
of believability because people can go
big all the time and then yeah they go
out just outside of rio
i don't know what it is keep it inside a
reel you're like i believe that this guy
would do that
yeah and that's when things are really
um special i think that's when a comedic
performance becomes special
it's when you're committed like that
it's just that's the old that's the old
thing in improv right there's only
commitment and non-commitment there's no
right or wrong yeah oh interesting yeah
yeah
uh you said as you stroke your beard
it's like this um
what is you what is your go-to karaoke
song
uh it used to be cherry cherry by neil
diamond oh neil diamond yeah any neil
diamond you can't go too wrong yeah okay
because obviously sweet caroline that's
you know that's a steak sure that's
almost too predictable it's
but
cherry cherry
catches on and uh coming to america
that's always a closer that's a closer
forever in blue jeans
blue jeans i mean
kentucky woman kentucky yes
neil neil never lets me down what
happens is then i get i get hammered and
i say i i when i sing journey i'd sing
it like i know i'm good because i hear
it running in the car
or am in the shower it's like it's
perfect now give it a minute yeah i'll
do it right now and yeah i realize
you're not steve perry and you're not
even close to it yeah and when you hear
your voice i tried to do journey a
couple times it is a recipe for disaster
uh yes i've done that and then you're
then you've got the microphone and
you've already you've already set
yourself up with the confidence when
you're in the shower you're in the car
it's like oh yeah [ __ ] sing anything
i sound like an angel do i really sound
this good i must because
i'm hitting every note here i'm hitting
every note who was your first celebrity
crush rob uh i am a child of the 80s
so uh it would have to be
heather locklear
yeah tj hooker days too i'm not even
talking like the pinup stuff i'm talking
tj hooker days because i remember
thinking oh wow super cute
charlie's angels fair fawcett uh sure
lad uh sure
jackson i mean just everybody
yeah everybody
yeah you um if you had to get a tattoo
what would you get
oh if i'd get a tattoo it'd probably be
you know a bald eagle across my entire
back so when i flexed it it looked like
it was flying
what is your favorite fruit i like a
crisp red apple can't do soft apples man
you bring me a soft apple you might as
well slap me in the face
it's the same exact thing it's the same
exact thing
so make it a crisp red apple and we're
friends for life i also like freezing uh
grapes in the freezer oh my brother
loves that christian
in the summer because you just i could
pop those all day when you oh they're so
good who would you want to play you in
your biopic
oh man
jack mcbrayer he's top two right now
um
sam rockwell
yep
oh man he would love it
he would get into it who's your favorite
muppet can i say uh
the two guys the two old guys uh oh yeah
statler and walters
yeah uh just i loved how they they just
sat there and yeah absolutely chromogens
and hecklers
and just served no i mean they just
never did anything to make things better
they just sat there and criticized
i have a question how much longer is
this thing going to last
i just love too because it's two classic
grumpy old dudes i'm like i know god
it's so but they're still they're still
a light-heartedness of them they're
still making each other laughs yeah
they're still enjoying each other like
they would crack each other you know
yeah
it's like those when you see those uh
old women sitting in a bar having their
white wine spritzers and they're like
they're 90 years old and they're you can
tell they've been causing trouble since
they were in the 30s
[ __ ] rascals yeah but they're still
yeah but there's still an enjoyment yeah
there's an enjoyment and like maybe they
have a relationship maybe they're you
know too old like queens but they're
just [ __ ] living their lives and like
having fun
uh
what's your go-to pizza topping i am a
pepperoni straight i'm a straight
shooter street shooter midwesterner yeah
then then similarly uh dogs are cats i'm
a dog guy
yeah
it's not that everything against cats
other than the fact that they're not
friendly at all
and i think they guard the gates to hell
you are you ketchup or mustard guy all
right you asked for it
yeah uh-oh i slam them together i stir
it up and it makes the greatest sauce
you've ever had it's a special sauce yes
ketchup and mustard and you can
ebb and flow go
46.60 with 60 40.
you play with the the ratio play with
the ratio depending on what you like
more but when you put them together and
really mix it now
don't play games just don't put it on
top of each other mix it up put it on
your burger you'll be hooked for life
okay i'm gonna do it i'm gonna try that
actually sounds good um rob i i i wish i
could give you a big hug through this
right here [ __ ]
i love you man i love you too buddy yes
this was the best i'm so glad we got to
do this i'm so glad you invited me i
really am i i've seen you with all these
people i'm like oh what does it take to
make the cut man with whatever no are
you kidding oh no we've been wanting
this for a while you're one of our
favorites congratulations to you by the
way on on your movie
i'm so happy for you the cast is amazing
and it's it's
funny
we got lucky you should be so happy
we're happy we're but i want we want to
do one with you so i'm going to send you
this script rob please i'm curious what
you think because i would love to do
something with you i would absolutely
count me in
sight unseen count me in okay oh good
it's about uh okay well you have to eat
a lot of uh soft apples and but pretty
good i'll let you know more
well
no no no that wasn't it you know you
don't have to do it
i know but i want to try it i think it's
a fun it's well we've committed to it
i guess when did that start um maybe 30
episodes ago i don't know
but it used to just be a neutral yeah so
that just happened yeah i know should we
go back to that well it's the new year
we don't we can set a precedent after
the new year you know we can do too late
we can i don't think it will change back
but what we could do is reserve
the impressions for someone who is fun
to do an impression of rob yeah or what
i mean or that we can do an impression
like if jane goodall dr jane goodall
wants to be on the show again yes
she's a wonderful one to do exactly yes
probably the polar opposite of rob
riggle but i bet they'd get along oh
because ryan you know why and why
because he seems like such a nice i know
they both do yeah they seem like they
would really get along well kind people
really kind of yeah you know what's
fascinating that i didn't i knew he was
in
the the reserves the marine reserves but
i didn't know i didn't know he had such
an activity i didn't either you don't
bother not know that rob riggle had an
act of duty in the marines i know i
didn't either it's such a wild
juxtaposition between
living this military life and having
followed these rules
then having this brilliant ability to
improvise and be funny and it it seems
like they would clash i know you asked
them you asked him about that i was so
interested in that
he was just like yeah i kind of did both
and like i i know made people laugh
so i was always under the afghanistan
and i was always under the impression
that though they could not coexist me
too yeah like shut up private like give
me 20 you know if you were out of line
at all maybe that's just from like
movies that we saw maybe bloxy blues
maybe but um but he does i mean it
he does play those kind of
imposing
like dominant
like yeah in fact when i'm bullyish kind
of
so effectively so like you see the
military oh yeah background in him but
he's so funny i know it's a really
interesting mix and like so sweet i know
but physically so imposing like i
remember when we did that macrame show i
that was his role was to be a um
i remember him like
push pushing around pc like drop and
give me 20. he was like a coach of some
sort or like
some real like authoritarian figure um
and he in between takes of course he was
so
so funny and like
playful like really playful but um
i was struck by what a juxtaposition
that was that he
did up to my eyes yeah
i think you know what it is with those
words i have to like run up it's like
i'm running out like i i have to like
give myself a running start yeah it's
like the triple jump and when i land
them when i land the words i'm like kind
of i have a moment of like like holy
[ __ ] i didn't do it
wow i said jackson position pow yeah
but it was funny i guess we didn't get
new chairs in the new year no 2023 maybe
squeak
he's fun oh he was so funny and like
really playful but like like he said so
good at being
this strong arm
authoritative figure you know and
physically
back then
more so in fact back then he was active
he i remember that's um
i remember him saying like he he could
kind of could get called at any time
uh and and he was in that kind of real
like top
shape like military shape you know he
was
huge back then
and and i i just i never met anybody
like that i wonder if directors or
producers or studios during that time
were reluctant to cast him because i
wonder about that
that's the thing with rob riggle like
even in the beginning of this episode we
were like what do we
talk about like what do we do you know
what's the thing he's known for and
somebody like rob is just like he's one
of those guys that's just like funny
you see him and you know it's going to
be funny but you can't always p you
can't necessarily pinpoint
i i couldn't anyway like what he's known
for this is the last
lightning round of the old lightning
round questions starting next week
through the new ones but i think this
was a good way to go out
because he had really good answers
really efficient good answers his
favorite snack is that
milano yeah double chocolate double
chocolate really into chocolate i was
frozen grapes oh yes amazing yes i
thought you'd like that karaoke song
cherry cherry by neil diamond a lot of
these are going to be retired these
questions and yeah i think he gave
really good uh like send off answers for
a lot of these questions you know i
think we might want to reintroduce the
your favorites we can't reintroduce
stuff yet we haven't even
haven't even heard the new ones
oh god sorry not to shame you but that
was an awful suggestion all right well
we can cut it out but now maybe it was
so bad that we want to leave it in now
warts and all so next week
new questions yes but for now let's read
a letter okay great pow pow no i see i
you you can't say power with if you
don't commit to it pow either i don't
want it like i can't yell it into a mic
you can
it's gonna hurt people's ears oh maybe
you gotta think there are people
listening to this
uh whoa this is a uh this is from shayna
singh
shayna singh nice name subject hi from
philly
hi justin and christian i'm shaina and
my favorite pepperidge farm cookies are
indeed milanos
you asked at the end of the alyssa
milano episode uh however i think there
are probably tons of amazing cookies i
haven't tried i'll work on that yeah
it's a good resolution for shayna
eat more cookies in the new year oh by
the way speaking of cookies i found some
that might rival chessmen shorties
ironically they're called shorties yes
how great shorties go pick up some
shorties yeah delicious and thanks to uh
my friend patty for introducing me to
them um okay patricia okay back to
shayna please don't spend a bunch of
time discussing how to say say my name
okay
it rhymes with dana yeah you got it i
said it right we didn't need the time
shayna
some people spell it with an i instead
of a y which i think is wrong okay
i'm a
i'm a 25 year old yeah phd student
living in philly but i wanted to tell
you a quick story about my first ever
job as a teenager in high school i
worked at a movie theater it was a
really old theater so it wasn't uh
usually very busy or heavily staffed
meaning that we were able to watch so
many full movies during our shifts i
always thought that would be cool too i
always found it to work in the theater
yeah
back to shaina assuming our manager
managers didn't come downstairs and we
had free unlimited movie tickets the
theater when we weren't on the clock as
well that's cool
during my years working there i became
way more aware of movies and figures in
hollywood i grew up watching movies of
course but during this time i got
serious i would guess that your biggest
film that was released during my time
working there was alvin and the chip
amongst the road chip
however classic title classic pun
classic title yeah however
was that the third that was the last one
equal was the second one yes
god you know i just saw that the first
one came out 14 years ago a couple weeks
ago
however back to shaina however you were
also in so many rom-coms that i would
watch on streaming services and on tv
during that time rom-coms are my
favorite movie type and you're
definitely one of my favorite rom-com
actors oh thanks shayna uh i love you in
the awkward but toxic male role
you are awkward and toxic yeah you mean
as a person
no as an actor um
yeah what is a character is she talking
about maybe he was just something yeah
and then she gave like a sideways
laughing cry laughing emoji i also just
love sappy movies with endings where the
couples somehow end up making it work
anyway i digress i so clearly remember
finding out that you were the voice of
one of the chipmunks when that movie
released and mentioning it to my friend
co-worker at the movies i told her about
how much i loved you in roncomes which
i would watch every single time i came
across them and she said quote yeah he
probably likes doing those indie type of
movies and then every few years actually
gets paid from doing a big animated
movie like the chipmunks and then end
quote is that true
anyway if you're actually reading this
then i'll it'll be super surreal for me
once i hear it on your podcast surreal
weird
yes you did like making money from
chipmunks movies didn't you yeah why
don't you answer that i would suspect
that
you didn't do those movies just for the
money i'm sure you also enjoyed the
process of voicing that character but i
would say the money probably didn't hurt
i was just talking about these movies um
and
someone asked me if they were fun to do
and
i said it was a little
it wasn't quite as fun as doing a
conventional animated movie because
we had to slow our voices down so much
to get
to get the the um
you know pitch up because with i think
i've talked about this before but like
jeff and dale they were they spoke fast
and at a high pitch but with alvin they
spoke at like more normal speeds so we
had to say everything like this
and
it was interesting but you know it's a
little bit you didn't enjoy it
i'm not saying that but it was i just
saw this and um so it was yeah it was a
good job
um and you're hoping they do more i
really do okay which is why i don't
really want to say it and enjoy it
because you like money
um i just saw this clip of um
willem dafoe alfred molina and jamie
foxx being interviewed for the new
spiderman i guess they're all in the new
spot they're all like reprisals yeah
it's all about like well spoilers
yeah they all like it's all peop from
past spider-man movies or whatever and
um and they willem dafoe just gives this
answer about playing the green goblin
again he's like yeah i thought it was
very a unique opportunity to revisit a
character and then they they they go
alfred molina who was the best is in the
middle and they go uh what about you
alfred he goes um i i just did it for
the money no
yes it's so good
he by the way we should get him on the
show he's f is it do you know him yeah
you do he came up you know everybody he
came up to me i don't know willem dafoe
he came up to me once at um in
williamstown he was like i and i had
heard he was there he was doing a play
and i was excited to meet him and he he
said justin justin i
and he said i saw you in
the other night and oh i'm so excited
you're so good and he was so like
overwhelmingly nice he like overwhelmed
me with
yeah wow that's so alfred molina thinks
you're a great actor yeah that's pretty
cool and he's nice cool i i did two
things with that story
um what what am i gonna leave that part
out here's the rest of sounding braggy
here's what i like about it it was just
a brag it wasn't a humble brag
that's just what he said yeah i know
that's cool
it was cool i'm gonna try to accept more
uh cool moments like yeah you should
yeah um i told that story because it's
part of my new year's resolution don't
backtrack no
okay so back to shayna uh why was i
talking about out from molina we should
get him on the show though
um where is that okay so surreal to here
we're talking about uh you cashing in to
do yeah alvin of the chipmunks yes well
another moment i told this i remember
there was up at the cabins that i i have
in massachusetts there was um we were
having like issues with these chipmunks
like chewing holes into the house and
like it was like an old-fashioned little
cabin and driving me nuts they were up
in the walls and stuff and and i at one
i was setting up traps and to no avail
and then i saw one appear in the middle
of the cabin and i just no i spotted it
and he was just sitting there like
really cute and i was but i was furious
because i built up such frustration
about these things damaging this
property whatever and i had a moment
where i went from being furious with
this thing
and i i was looking and it dawned on me
that the reason i was able to buy this
cabin was because of
this creature that chipmunk is that
irony i think so
is it yeah i guess so it's something
well and i never had negative feelings
about them again i thought well mikasa
sukasa you little furry friend thanks
for uh being so adorable well i hope
you're never in a movie called termites
well if i am i would probably have a
similar it wouldn't be as cute
not a bad idea for a movie
okay
uh back to shayna my phd is focused on
spinal cord research wow and i study the
cells in the spinal cord that control
the rhythm of locomotion walking oh my
god
it sounds cool but it's really
complicated i'm sure it sounds both cool
and yeah yeah
yes it being cool it's not one of the
other exactly those can easily coexist
in fact often do
uh sounds cool but it's really
complicated i'm in my third year of my
phd so i'm starting to get cynical and
pessimistic about everything
while i do my long experiment while i do
my long experiments and i love listening
to your podcast especially the parts
about the business of hollywood uh-oh i
hope we don't do too much of that um
maybe that just stems from my obsessive
movie watching days back when i had my
first job
uh and now oh would you rather
okay
would you rather be in a long-distance
relationship from minimum of five years
before you could live in the same
country as your partner
or be guaranteed to meet the ultimate
love of your life seven years from now
um
that's
the way the first one the five years
five years there's no guarantee that a
good relationship yeah so easily in your
seven years yeah easily i
i was
if you know that the five year one is
the love of your life and you just have
to be teased for five years yeah
i would do that because it would be the
anticipation it would be fun but maybe
it's implied but can you imagine how
miserable it would be to
wait five years and then and then the
person gets there and you're like that
doesn't work not only doesn't work but
you like don't like them or something
well wouldn't you yeah or you don't like
certain things about that like what
i don't know so
certain things that you would only
discover if you're living in the same
country oh like how they smell or no
like what type of restaurants they like
going to well you would know that if
you're a long distance
um okay yeah definitely the second one
but
if there is see this is why these things
always work better when they're really
clear
not to would you rather shame you shayna
um but uh yeah definitely the second one
and and seven years is like if you're
talking about the ultimate love of life
like that doesn't seem like a lot i mean
unless you die in six years
oh yeah that's true but but but still
then you've lived
six years
of like comfort without the wrong person
but just waiting but if the five year
one then you get
let's say you die six years from now
then the long distance relationship won
would benefit you because then you have
to wait five years and in the last year
of your life you get to finally be you
get to spend that last year
with with this person that you're in a
relationship oh that's true
yeah i know not now i'm confused like
five years before you could live in the
same place as your part
it's not clear if that's the love of
your life
if it's not
then you can definitely stop it yes okay
shayna p.s oh then she says ps your
instagram is hilarious thank you shayna
instagram yeah in general i i guess so i
do have a generally funny instagram page
well i haven't done it in a while i
haven't been on instagram well i should
because i haven't posted about the show
in a while i gotta get back in there
yeah you should start talking right now
i know i know i noticed that you'd stop
doing that i just gotten lazy and not
been on it as much i guess but it's so
easy to do one a week i know you know
for the good of the show but you know
when you run behind when you get behind
then it's like uh then
you i don't know i get stressed about it
well thank you shane yeah thank you for
writing man that was a great letter and
if you guys would like to write in our
email address
is life is short at wondery.com
and pow pow
thank you to rob riggle pow pow funny
kind how sweet pow generous how
flattering wow compared to steve carrell
and jason bateman man yeah um what a guy
i know wow what a guy i know those are
great and i think his daughter is going
to do well as an actress because
um for one thing she has a father like
him who gives her very sage advice yeah
working hard and being committed to
something something that he did in his
life so um i bet she's on the right
track well said well said and um and i
think we're on the right track starting
the year
off with a great guest and with maybe an
efficient ending coming up from me maybe
i'm gonna try the way i got into the
show i'm gonna try to leave the show as
efficiently so thank you for listening
thanks to rob thanks to you where's your
hand on my waist okay and uh we'll we'll
see you next week happy new year
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
life short is hosted by me justin long
it is co-hosted and produced by you
christian law it's also produced by
katie v allen and megan v monaco senior
producers michelle
nishlands and audio engineer is sergio
the enriquez the executive producer is
the one and only marshall he's our
favorite marshall louis it's for a
company i think it's the only company i
know of named wondery
[Music]
song of my heart so if there's a quiet
moment i'm a guy that's singing humming
that type of thing
i'm not someone who
yes i'm not the kind of guy who fits
into one peg necessarily what does that
mean
how do you fit into a peg
you mean
i'm not a peg who fits into many things
yes
he's the peg
does he know what a peg is
he could fit into one peg but he
gestured like he was putting a peg into
something
maybe he thinks the peg is the hole
the baby thinks peg's a person
by the way that's the only explanation
you can fit into one but he's nervous he
doesn't know what a peg is he's just
nervous it's either he doesn't know what
a peg is or he's talking about a person
named peg
he's also not serious when he says
when there's a moment of silence i feel
it by humming or singing i'm sure he
doesn't do that with everybody by the
way i hope he's serious
this season will come a lot funnier
imagine him on a date and there's like a
moment of silence and he starts
i have hope
i don't think so
in fact i don't think there'll be a
single moment where he uh he'll sing
because he's probably like a wanted
he'll sing to like be able to further
his career yes
but he won't sing to like
or his hummingbird
you